joe after spending what 1.3 million on
legal fees for crude in 2011
you expressed concerns about being able
to make
documentaries in the future especially
about legal cases
so what changed and how were you able to
make whitey
yeah um well
as you know the crude lawsuit was very
draining
emotionally financially psychologically
um and actually that was in 2010
and there was one day i was sitting at
my kitchen table with my wife writing
some very big checks to lots of lawyers
and you know and i said if something
doesn't change you know we could lose
everything
luckily things did change and you know i
i
emerged from crude from that lawsuit you
know okay
um but i had become disillusioned about
whether documentaries can really affect
change and
if this is the price you have to pay
maybe i need to rethink my career
but then that year was bookended
beautifully
in august of 2011 a year exactly a year
later from that day where i was writing
all these big checks
it was announced that the west memphis
three were getting out of prison
and of course the films you know the
paradise lost series played a big role
in that because it was kind of
those films you know while i don't want
to take
full credit or even anything close to
that because
a lot of very unique circumstances came
together
and tens of thousands of people you know
very generously agitated for the
you know the release of the west memphis
three and notable celebrities came in
and
you know a unique set of circumstances
came together to release the west
memphis three or
four to put pressure on the authorities
but the films
were the catalyst for that and so after
having had a horrible year
getting clobbered in my lawsuit against
chevron
i had you know the opposite experience
where i saw
the power of documentaries that you know
films can affect positive social change
that they had a deep
impact on uh on the west memphis iii
case
and thankfully that renewed my spirit
and uh
i got out of my doldrums and i you know
carried on
and so the next big project that came
along was
the whitey bulger film and you know
luckily cnn films encouraged me to make
that film
and so i did not have to struggle for
financing on that one cnn
you know paid for it so it wasn't really
so much about the money
it was more about the emotional
fortitude it requires to make these
kinds of films to enter into these kinds
of worlds
the battles you have to undertake
to you know get your story out there
and after the crude experience and you
know i
i had i had a little bit of the life
drained out of me but thankfully with
the release of the west memphis 3
i'm back in business and then made and
decided
and decided to make the whitey bulger
film well speaking of too long
no no it's beautiful and actually i'm
gonna skip around because
keeping with that so using documentary
filmmaking is a form of activism
what do you want people to see about the
whitey bulger case
yeah you know you have to be a little
careful about just saying
documentaries are an advocacy tool of
course they are but
i think you can't just be an advocate
you also have to be a storyteller and
certain people make
films for different reasons and
certainly storytelling and cinema
for the sake of cinema which i think is
a dying art in some ways
is certainly a valid reason to make
films
you know so all of those are present in
anything i undertake
but the thing i want people to walk away
from
with regard to the whitey bulger film is
that i think the true story
of what enabled bulger to
reign over a criminal empire for 25
years
without even so much as being stopped
for a traffic ticket i think that real
story hasn't been told
and just because bulger has been
convicted
which is good he deserves to be
convicted the film is not an apology for
whitey bulger he's a brutal vicious
killer that deserves to be behind bars
but
what enabled him to reign
there's a level of corruption in my
opinion a corruption of our institutions
of justice that needs to be looked at
because we can't allow this to happen
again
and when carmen ortiz
who is the u.s attorney for the district
of massachusetts at the end of the
bulger trial and you see this moment at
the end of our film
stands before the assembled press that
was covering the trial and said
with the conviction of james whitey
bulger this ugly chapter in boston's
history is now
we hope it can be closed i'm
paraphrasing somewhat
but in my opinion how can we close this
chapter if we don't
know who was responsible for allowing
bulger
to kill and if you believe he was an fbi
informant as
is the conventional story it's bad
enough that
institutionally they look the other way
as he
killed and did all sorts of terrible
things
while an fbi informant but as the film
demonstrates there are some troubling
aspects to whether or not he really was
an informant
and so if his protection
as a criminal afforded to him by some
people in the fbi
and the department of justice was not as
the result of being an informant
but through some other deeper level of
corruption then we really need to know
how that happened and all of this is
because i think
and the main message i want to get out
in this film
or the main activism is that i think the
families of victims
whether they were some of the victims
were fellow criminals but some of the
victims were
innocent bystanders and in one case
roger wheeler a very successful
legitimate businessman gunned down at a
country club
in oklahoma you know these families of
victims regardless of what
whether they were a criminal or a legit
businessman the families of these
victims deserve
answers as to how their loved ones were
allowed to be killed by a criminal who
should have been brought
in to justice much earlier
i don't believe you know agencies of the
government
should be allowed to pick and choose who
should live and who should die
in their zeal to bring down the italian
mafia
they look the other way again whether he
was an informant or not an informant
which
is one of the central questions of the
film in both scenarios
he was allowed to kill
while the fbi and the department of
justice focused on bringing down the
italian mafia
and so they decided that was the goal to
bring down the italian mafia and in
boston we're going to look the other way
as to what the italian sorry as to what
the
irish gangsters are going to do here and
i don't think the government should be
in that business allowing certain people
to
you know get away with criminality while
they
you know close down others so when you
heard about whitey bulger being found
in santa monica was that the catalyst
for you wanting to do the film or had
you been following
his whole story for years well
interestingly um
well maybe it's just interesting to me
but interestingly um
you know i have long been fascinated by
the bulger saga
it is an irresistible narrative
ruling over the boston criminal empire
for 25 years not even so much as being
stopped for a traffic ticket
the fbi not bringing him to justice
pressure from the massachusetts state
police
ultimately belatedly forcing an
investigation that led to an indictment
that in turn led to the fbi tipping him
off and him going on the lamb
it's an incredible narrative and frankly
i never thought he was going to be
brought in to justice i like many
thought he was hiding in plain sight and
never to be
brought in and i was also
fascinated always as a media maker
at the cottage industry of the bulger
franchise as a story i mean i've never
seen a
criminal so pass into the modern
kind of myth-making cultural
machine to the point where some people
think he's a hero
and dozens of books have been written
about him and johnny depp is shooting a
movie and jack nicholson played
bulger or some form of a bulger loosely
based on him in the departed and
so i've been long fascinated by all
these elements but never thought i had
anything to add
precisely because there is a glut of
media about the guy each
each piece with its own spin as to who
whitey bulger is
um so when he was actually arrested
as a follower of the story i was
surprised
my ears then started to prick up you
know i started to pay attention but
when it was finally announced that he
was being
actually going to be brought back to
massachusetts and the date was announced
and he was standing trial
then i thought along with cnn that
this could be a really compelling film
that finally i would have something to
add to the story
um because i could use the the trial the
present tense springboard of the trial
to kind of separate the man from the
myth and to really explore who this
person is versus
these you know mythologies that have
been created
you know and non-fiction books i
shouldn't say everything is a mythology
you know there are there's some
legitimate reporting that has gone on
but
you know each each book kind of has its
own spin and so i wanted to
use the trial to try to understand for
myself
who who whitey bulger is and more
importantly
what allowed him to be possible and
lastly you
approached cnn films or who invested
in the film what was the cnn films and i
were in conversation
uh about doing a film and this subject
came up and we both kind of just
grabbed for the opportunity so cnn films
was hugely supportive
and it was a good opportunity